hey guys it's justine and i am so
excited about this video because today i
am unboxing the goal zero yeti 1000 core
and this thing is so incredible and so
powerful i've been using one of the
really small versions of this but this
one can power so many things over here
it says fridges smokers tvs blenders
camera equipment lights personal
electronics and more this is quiet it's
gas free and it can also be charged with
solar and i'm such a huge fan of goal
zero they have so many amazing products
so a huge thank you to goldzero for
sponsoring this video i can't wait to
show you guys this and then i'm actually
gonna be taking this out and filming a
podcast with my sister and we're gonna
be using this to power everything our
computers our cameras if we need a light
we're going to use this to power the
light i can't wait for this mini podcast
adventure let's open this thing up
okay i just got i got i got to stand up
paperwork
wow
look at this
oh
look at this this is a cute little
station here we've got our charger
before using restoring plug your gold
air right into the wall until it is
fully charged to keep your gold zero
yeti plugged in when not in use to
ensure it's always ready this will not
cause harm to your battery oh that's
actually good to know this has so many
awesome ports on it for charging various
devices these are the two inputs that
you can use to charge from goal zero
solar panels or ac here we have our 12
volt outputs we have our interactive
buttons here in the lcd so we have four
usb ports we have in and out usbc we
have two regular usba and we have this
18 watt usbc you've also got these ac
power so you can power traditional
things like your computer or a
refrigerator or a coffee machine i will
definitely be finding use for these oh
and inside here they even have an input
for charging and it even has a 12 volt
output as well this is
so great so between solar and if you
have this plugged in directly to the
wall it can charge fully in about nine
hours but they do have a 230 watt
charger they can actually charge this
within four and a half hours now let's
unbox these solar panels this is a
really big box i'm gonna put this on the
ground
wow
this can't even fit in my screen
check this out
oh
wow okay look at this
our little pouch here this is what we
connect to the yeti for best results
point your panel directly towards the
sun one would think that would be a
common sense thing but now you know
whoa
look at this
here it is
this is
oh my goodness
look at these panels
this is so
incredible we have
four
panels here i feel like i can power my
entire house with this all right so
clearly i can't set this up in my house
because it is meant to be outside so i'm
gonna go set this up and start off on
our podcast adventure
so we're here at the location and we're
gonna start setting up for our podcast
but the first thing that i'm gonna do is
get those solar panels all set up so
that we can start making sure that
everything is fully charged i mean this
entire device is going to be powering
everything that we're doing today our
podcast equipment the cameras our phones
in case they need to be charged so these
are the solar panels i didn't really get
a chance to check these out in the
studio so you guys are experiencing this
first hand i love that this just all
folds up so nicely
[Music]
look at that
that means we are getting power
[Music]
so you don't necessarily need to use
this light right now but i just want to
test this out to make sure that one day
when we do need to use it and power it
it's going to work okay jen
here you go all right
plugging in
it's so nice i love it all right oh my
gosh it's on suns we don't even need to
stay for sunset we just take this
[Music]
oh it's so bright that's only 50 really
that's so bright it actually feels like
the sun oh my goodness wow okay that's
uh good to know for future when we
actually need a light oh my god it's so
bright just turn it off
[Music]
the sun is already shifting so by the
time we start recording the sun is
probably going to be about this angle so
let's move these a little bit jen just
so we can get maximum
sun coverage
[Music]
so this is the real test will it be able
to power our podcasting gear oh
it's on it's on
podcast is all set up looks good sounds
good we're charged up this is great yeah
can you hear me yeah i can hear you so i
said it sounded good when we started
this podcast like this is what we wanted
to do we wanted to go out in nature have
adventures and now that we have this
like we can yeah i feel like we were
really limited to like being in a car
and close to a car with extension cords
and cables but we're good now like we
are we're basically in the lake
we
will we ever do a boat podcast we could
it's like it's honestly limitless like
as long as we can like pick this thing
up take it somewhere and it's charged
and with solar panels like our options
are have
been expanded the world is our oyster do
you remember when we did one car podcast
and we didn't realize that the car
sometimes would shut off yes and then i
remember that and we were like oh we
lost all the audio i think yep great
times we're not going to have that
problem anymore
anywhere we have sun or we've got to
charge it up yeti we're good to go i
know i'm very excited but goal zero is
awesome they have so many cool products
i got you that smaller one it was the
500. i know it's great i just need to go
on an adventure now but it's so funny
because i use that to just charge my
phone like anytime i'm like i don't even
use an outlet i just like pick that up
and i use it well it's good to have
because you never know with like there's
been a lot of weird weather and weird
things happening like i feel like it's
just a good thing to have charged all
the time in your home in case of
emergencies yeah that's it we did it if
you want to listen to the full podcast
check out our youtube channel
youtube.combrain
you can also find us basically
everywhere the podcasts are like a thing
we also have personal channels but
that's what you're on yeah so i have a
personal channel don't go there no go
check out jenna anyway i'll see you guys
in the next video hope you guys enjoyed
this i will put a link in the
description if you want to check out
more incredible goal zero products and
the goal zero 1000 core yeti that we're
using right now it's so cool can i plug
my body into it to charge me up i don't
think that the lawyers would like that
okay it was a joke yeah she's joking
it's a joke okay we'll see you later bye
[Music]